très critique vis-à-vis du Parti
socialiste mais réservant tout de même
ses propos les plus durs au président de
la République tel est apparu George
Marchet qui tenait hier soir à Rennes
son 29e meeting politique l'intervention
du secrétaire général du PCF a duré 2h
et il a constitué un véritable
réquisitoire du septena qui se termine
meeting au demeurant mouvementé à
l'intérieur de la salle omnisport comme
à l'extérieur du fait de la présence
d'antinucléaire et de militants
d'extrême
gauche dans une salle omnisport bien
remplie ils se sont comptés 6000 hier
soir George Marchet pouvait se féliciter
d'avoir réuni le plus important meeting
qu'il est jamais tenu à Rennes dès avant
de se rendre à la tribune le secrétaire
général du PC saisissait l'atmosphère de
la soirée plusieurs centaines de
manifestants étaient massés à l'entrée
principale de la salle omnisport et ceux
d'entre eux qui réussissaient à pénétrer
se sont fait entendre durant toute la
Réunion scandant essentiellement deux
noms Kabou et
plogof
pendant que de jeunes militants aés nous
empêchaient de filmer les contestataires
George Marchet entamait un discours de 2
he par un bilan impitoyable du septena
mais c'était pour dénoncer aussitôt les
dangers d'un consensus à 3 psrpr
UDF j'ai
biencience qu'en évoquant de tel
fait car je n'ai fait que souligner des
faits je m'expose à me faire
mais George March voilà il a encore
attaqué François
Mitra je veux donc profiter de
l'occasion qui m'est donné ce soir à Ren
pour faire une mise au
point mon
objectif est-ce comme je l'entends dès
que je tourne le le bouton de la radio
ou de la
télévision de taper le plus fort
possible dès que j'en ai l'occasion sur
François
mon adversaire est-ce le Parti
socialiste non absolument
pas mon adversaire c'est la politique de
chômage de privation pour les
travailleurs de restriction des libertés
et d'abandon
national c'est cette politique là que je
combats c'est son
aggravation voulu prévue programmé par
le patronat que je veux empêcher si donc
je suis
amené à souligner les prise de position
de François mitran et à en montré les
dangers ce n'est pas pour le plaisir de
critiquer
mitran c'est parce que je ne veux pas
lui permettre de sauver la politique de
Giscard destin cette politique que je
combat 2hures plus tôt dans une
conférence de presse George Marchet
avait fait connaître la lettre ouverte
qu'il adresse au breton à propos du
nucléaire à ceux qu'il fustige comme des
nostalgiques de la lampe à huile faux
écologistes mais vrais anticommunistes
il s'est encore adressé hier soir pour
défendre la position du
PC voilà pourquoi nous disons oui il
faut une centrale nucléaire de grande
puissance en Bretagne
à George Marchet reviendra aussi sur les
problèmes de l'immigration pour dénoncer
le risque de constitution de ghetto de
nouveau soveto ou de nouveaux Harlem il
développera les 131 propositions du
Parti communiste pour promouvoir une
politique nouvelle un espoir qui peut
a-t-il dit se transformer en réalité il
nous reste pour cela 3 mois